we put out a video on common cars and
everyone got in the comments with
you know some hot take and um and some
not hot
i'm just so disappointed uh do people
not know the difference between morality
and legality
just because something is illegal does
not make it morally wrong but just on
the point of legality versus morality
for a long time for you for for people
who are staying there like oh it's
illegal so it's his pro
you guys not realize that's the same
logic they used to imprison minorities
for my
for minor defenses for so long now that
they're making it legal
for tax revenue everyone's turned a
blind eye
ruined communities they're making it a
business rough
and i'm going to show you how little
sense this whole situation makes
go ahead so here's a lot in place the
lawn place says that any sharing of
pictures of
someone under the age of 18 is rock
now on its face value it sounds great
sounds perfectly fine
but tell me how this makes sense a 17
year old can take out hundreds of
thousand dollars worth of student loans
a 17 year old
can drive a vehicle a 17 year old army
can join the military and go after war
a 17 year old can even choose to
legally sleep with a 19 year old in most
states but if that 17 year old wants to
send a picture of herself
to a 19 year old there's something wrong
or if she gets asked and she agrees to
do it
there's something wrong does that make
sense no hold up does that make sense no
hold on it's not illegal for the 17 year
old to send it
but it's illegal for the 19 year old to
receive it
no actually that's not it's illegal for
both of them because
her taking even pictures of herself in
some situations can be considered that
too
oh wow so tell me how this makes sense
preach
he's going to be the irian one she can
be inside her he just can't have a
picture of her
he can be inside her but he can't have a
i don't even like cider right
bro and you know i want to calm you down
how stupid this law is they charged a 17
year old and a six-year-old who were in
a cup who were a couple
for sending pictures of themselves to
each other a 17 year old and a 16 year
old were
charged with this law in place
because they were sending pictures of
themselves to each other a
13 year old and a 14 year old were also
charged with using the same law
because they were sending pictures of
themselves to each other when they were
in a relationship
now look i'm not advocating that people
be sending off pictures of themselves
like that's not my point
we also just have to get out of this
mindset because something is
said by the government that somehow you
should be behind it it used to be
illegal
for black folks to be involved with
white folks in a romantic setting
do you think it like i just question
whether people thought about this beyond
it's illegal
some laws are in place that are stupid
in connecticut you can't sell a pickle
unless it bounces when you put it on
does that make sense in some states you
cannot it's forbidden to have a ice
cream in your back pocket
yo you're it's illegal to go to our
kansas and and say the name wrong
arkansas or kansas there's kansas you
put an r
before it that's right i agree oh it's
only
guys make that make sense for you he can
be inside her but he can't take a
picture of her
due to the romeo and juliet laws most
people in most states including the
state that carson lived in
he can't sleep with her but he can't
have a picture of her [ __ ] does that
make sense to you
really you know the thing is do you
understand why it's like that
because people have no time for nuance
i think the real problem is that we've
given too many people a voice
and and abilities to speak on everything
and the truth is
everyone wants to exercise their right
to speak but very few want to exercise
their responsibility to listen and to
learn
people just yapping cancer cows okay
you haven't even thought these issues
through you haven't you haven't looked
at it at all people don't want to read
anything beyond the headline
laziness it's super lazy but it's super
easy to be like it's illegal and then
like it forces you not to think right of
course but then it also
removes not only the context but the
humanity of the people involved yeah
because
you're making this person out to you're
criminalizing regular teenage behavior
and let me be clear a 19 year old is
just as much a teen
as an 18 or a 17 year old it's literally
in the definition of the word
but it comforts people to have that
security
to know what is going on stupid people
are not
comfortable with gray areas
you understand what i'm saying yeah so
all the gray areas
because they're gray areas they do not
want to spend time to think
so they want to remove the gray areas it
was it has to be all black or all white
if you remove the gray area then people
don't need to think
that equals that i didn't think today i
just i just saw it you know what i mean
like it's just like it's going to become
just like right now whenever you say
two plus two you don't have to think
about it it's four
you know what i mean it's very so it
removes the ability of people to just
think and it's just
it's magic it's just magic it's just
that's the answer
and that it makes no sense no it doesn't
make any sense but
that's what happens in people's brain
imagine you're 17 years old yeah 11
months have gone by 30 days
23 hours and 59 seconds illegal a second
goes by
it's magic but it's also a matter like
people don't want to admit their own
ignorance or
or accept that and the reality is we're
all ignorant to so much
it's okay that's what happens okay when
you talk
when you talk about ignorance it just
makes me think of
the laws that we have and you're talking
about gravity so if you put an apple in
the air
and it falls down you know it's gravity
most
people cannot explain to you what actual
gravity is
and what the forces of gravity is but
they know
gravity so whenever they see someone
making magic
it doesn't make sense to them they're
like oh [ __ ]
and they can't comprehend it because
they understand they can't explain it
but to a person that knows yeah there's
a trick there you could do this and this
and fake it
you know what i mean so that's a bit
what happens with the laws the laws
you put them there so people can be like
it's illegal it's gravity
and not think about that they don't have
to think about it you understand
but whenever there's a situation that's
very gray they're like yeah but it's
supposed to be illegal it's impossible
it doesn't
cannot compute and he can't function
it's really that it's
it's you know the problem is though is
that when you walk through life and you
want to comment on things with such
certainty
as if they weren't magic that's the
problem when you don't acknowledge the
fact that you believe in magic
right and you're like well sandra why
did you give him a million dollars of
your life savings
magic because he does magic no because
he runs a scam and you're an idiot
but you're not able to see that because
you're like oh you
yeah you got you he did the sparkles you
guys did a couple car tricks
i gotta invest so it's just it's it's
faulty thinking
it's faulty thinking and the problem is
there's real life consequences for
people involved when people like well
then look at the text messages
first off i've got a huge problem with
reading people's private messages
like there's something very like
perverse about everyone's like
let's get some tea out and let's go read
these dm's that someone
first off you have the whole transcript
it's creeping down but also recognize
you know like okay you look at the dms
right
really that's manipulative the reason
why you think it's manipulative the real
reason is because you walked in with a
narrative
and when you're reading these text
messages which are often out of context
that don't include the full length of
conversations between two people
you've already primed yourself to
believe it is what it is in that same
token when i'm at a park
and a little kid runs up to my leg and i
try to walk away
you think something shifty happened when
i recognized that people are already
primed to view certain people
a certain way you see a black dude
in a neighborhood late at night as
you're walking towards you most of us
are already primed to see that person a
certain way
so you have to recognize the bias that
you're going in when you're reading
those messages
i had a girl one time i was i remember
being 20 and this girl was talking to me
and we were talking about meeting up
blah blah blah and then a week out she
started to feel guilty
and she's like i don't think i could do
this i'm hyper religious
you know you don't believe in the same
faith blah blah blah
she's going on all this emotional stuff
and it's okay and i'm like you know what
we don't have to meet up
was she trying to emotionally manipulate
me or
did she just have real insecurities that
she was sharing
how do i know and how do you know who
don't even know her
but you'll read a couple texts messages
this is what it is no no there's two
type of people in the world
abba it's just horrible they're gonna
come in with this [ __ ]
yeah you don't know you don't know what
he was trying to do
i read it you know what it looked like
it looked like an awkward dorky ass
19 year old who's probably been
unpopular most of his life
and now he's got a whole bunch of
adulation women who are interested and
he's conflicted
that's another i'm not saying it is that
i'm saying there's
a possibility but you know what i didn't
do i didn't put a referendum on his
character after reading a few messages
because i don't know him neither do you
so for you to play armchair psychology
to be like this is
textbook narcissism you don't know what
textbook narcissism look like you
aren't educated enough to know so why
would you like even
us bro this is one thing i've actually
not felt good about and it's like
bothering me for some time
remember when we did that man the seals
video and we were and we were like oh uh
she's acting like a narcissist or
whatever right
the only reason i was even saying that
was because she felt so comfortable
calling other people that that i use
that log
but even to this date it doesn't make me
feel comfortable because i don't have
the aptitudes for it
i just i can't fathom for the life of me
how people
try to come up to these like certified
110 conclusions
based off of limited information you do
what i'm saying because people
like to know that they know it's like if
you ask people what
do you want your superpowers to be and
reading the minds come
coming like in in the in the tops you
know people want to read minds
people want to know what you're thinking
people want to think
they know what you're thinking they know
this they know that
who predicted it or you're virgo that's
because you're
you're you're you are a hair
sign so it means this and that and that
oh you're this
so you're you are a dog
in the lunar they want to know what
people they want to think they know
how people are going to act how people
are going to be able to behave
you know what and i'm not even mad at
that if you
want to pontificate go ahead
but acknowledge that it's pontification
that's all don't be out there speaking
with such certitude of who people are
when you don't know that's the only
thing that bothers me about this whole
situation we had that case here in
montreal where people got super mad at
me
right because a guy was dating a girl
and he was overweight
all right and they hadn't slept together
even though they were dating for months
and then one night he actually was like
you
it because i'm like unattractive and
ugly and fat like because he has his
insecurities
and she's like no no it's not i really
want to do and they slept together and
later on
she claimed that he manipulated her that
was that that's the story she told she
has the details
that's the details that she gave did he
manipulate you or did he not just share
his insecurities with you
you know we love to tell dudes share
your emotions isn't that but when they
do oh they're trying to immediately
manipulate you
to get brother i'm still unknown on that
one you know i am still unknown
people want me to share man bro people
want you to share so they can use it
against time
yeah i know yeah yeah a lot of times i
don't know all the time
and even even some people like even even
to my friends i don't share my [ __ ]
no i know cause there's there's a cost
to this yeah
there's something that could potentially
happen and
i'm just gonna be mad if you i'm just
gonna be super mad not even at you at
myself if
you actually use it against me in a
context that has nothing to do with what
i said or what i did
so yeah no i shut the [ __ ] up i just
keep to myself
it's just and that's that yeah it's just
disappointing it almost feels like
everyone is so ready to throw
rocks from glass houses like they didn't
send cringy messages at 18 or 19 or
if i didn't go through their dm's i
wouldn't find like conversations that
could be interpreted she's like everyone
needs to chill man
everyone needs to just take a step back
and acknowledge the fact that
he's a 19 year old who gained fame over
the last little while and there's nobody
to help guide him
no people like to judge he should know
better what 19 year old knows better
what 18 year old with all that adulation
knows better
look at every child star every child
famous person they all come out a little
crooked in some type of way
there's a low hand there's nobody there
to guide you
there's nobody there to to to mentor you
in most of those situations
because there's not too many people
who've gone through it even rather than
being like yo
let's help educate people the first
thing we go to is like
your trash your garbage your why
and people think that in the same
situation they're gonna they would do
better
oh well if i put myself in their shoes
most of the time when people say
oh well i put myself in there no you
didn't put yourself in their shoes
you but it wasn't if i wasn't at this
place where her place you didn't put
yourself in her or his place
you put yourself at your place
looking at her place you were right
there you're like yeah
if i was there it'd be i'd do much
better but you don't have the whole
context
that's that's a lot of people
that's even me in the past that's a lot
of people tell us what you guys think in
the comments below
[Music]
today's topic what did you want to talk
about
what did i want to talk what did you
want to talk about not about what you
want to talk about
i didn't want to talk about [ __ ] [ __ ]
what you want to talk about okay all
right then i'm going to move to my
motherfucker's like yeah did they stop
it what you want to talk about i felt
like you want to talk about something no
no
before we were talking about something
you feel like you want to talk about it
now i'm always pissed off about some
[ __ ] but i mean it's just you know it's
just it
it just is what is yeah all right
last night i uh i got triggered super
trigger
okay and um
and i couldn't i just started writing
and when i write it's normally not the
greatest thing
i was going to come at this like super
high rate but i'm like let me just
breathe and chill
no that's my job because if you come
with the super irate you're [ __ ] up
the whole thing yeah but i got feelings
i want to let out
no no no that's my job hey don't be
toxic let me express myself i'm not
saying no but usually that's not how you
my feelings can i express myself in a
spectrum of ways
yes in the way that you're used to
express yourself
are you pigeonholing me no i'm not i'm
just saying it sounds like you're
pigeonholed
no just do your thing but you can't [ __ ]
this whole energy here now i got to be
calm and i want to be calm
i don't want to be you want to switch it
up i mean
not real enough